ومع نهايه السنه بدات المنصات والتطبيقات
والشركات كلها تنزل احصائياتها وتقاريرها
السنويه وفي عالم الموسيقى سبوتيفاي راب
تحدث بيستناه مستخدمي التطبيق من السنه
للسنه وفي الشركه بتعرض لكل مستخدم تقرير
مفصل لك عن ايش
سمعوا المفضل وهكذا والناس كلها بتتحمس
على رجوله وكانوا نتيجه امتحان ولما ينزل
كمان بيعلقوا وبينكوا بيضحكوا عليه ومن
وقت ما نزل الاسبوع الفايبر
وهي عينه من التعليقات والنكت من
المستخدمين العرب واجانب على الموضوع
لكن زي ما اكون مستخدم له اسبوع كمان
الاستماع على التطبيق كله وفي تفاعلكم
زوجونا باحصائيات عن الفنانين والاغاني
الاكثر استماعا خلونا نستعرضها سوا وخلونا
نبدا في الشرق الاوسط هذه هي اكثر اغاني
سماعات واكثر فنانين عرب كمان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اما في السعوديه الان وما اكثر الفنانين
السعوديين اجتماعا على 22
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]